the abnormal things I were doing to get
the drug was was horrific
um and the first five years of addiction
I used to go around like universities
and stuff and pretend I was a lost
student and black people for many
um yeah I used to make quite a lot of
money doing that
um and then it was only towards the
second half of my addiction
um when I started to become a a
shoplifter and again up and down the
country shoplifting
um but it was just pure desperation the
whole time sheer desperation
and how many times are you in prison
10 11 times 10 I know I've been I've
been on probably
15 20 methadone Scripts
kicked off started again where it's just
a
Vicious Circle type of thing so um yeah
every time I come out of prison I was
you know back to using